[Music]
tam I need to confess something what do
you do I feel like the worst person in
the world you can kill someone did you
come to think of it where is Sam steps
behind the camera yeah myself ok I don't
like Telltale's Game of Thrones what I
know I've read all the books I've seen
all of the show I'm teaching myself
Dothraki which is an actual thing you
can do you know I just I'm not feeling
it and I'm trying to figure out why and
I think I know go on then tell me all
about it
doctor like this you heard it is no I
bought the whole season upfront I kind
of like the first episode it laid a lot
of groundwork it had a twist that Martin
himself would have been proud of and it
introduced a whole bunch of new
characters maybe too many I get that
they're mimicking the throne style of
different viewpoints dotted all around
the map and whatever but five playable
characters but just seems excessive and
they all look exactly the same so
positives then the world certainly looks
and feels the part the music's great and
the remade intro is a nice touch um for
starters the characters house Forrester
is basically how stark 2.0 and you'd
think that it'd be okay because the
Starks are like these cool northerners
to the point anyway the forest is full
foul of the same problem I have with
most of Telltale's protagonists they
just feel too passive granted that so
you can pour yourself into each
character and mold your own story but
the characters by themselves should have
other redeeming traits than boy bearded
boy and girl the best sequences are the
encounters with characters like Cersei
Tyrion and Jon Snow not just because
they're familiar faces but because
they're interesting they have
personality and motives that they don't
wear on their sleeves but my main
problem is with the story or rather that
we've seen it all before
the forest is a conveniently placed in
the exact areas which hits the fan the
game starts at the red wedding Garrard
is gonna be involved in the battle at
the wall mirrors gonna be involved in
the purple wedding well you don't know
that oh come on it's all just too
convenient while they're exciting plot
points that we all discussed around the
water cooler this will be the third time
we've seen them play out
no real surprise coming even if stuff
happens directly to the Forester family
I just don't feel committed enough to
them to really care which you know kind
of sounds awful when you put it like
that we've read the books we've seen the
show and now we've played the game for
me it's just too much I'd rather it
taking the walking-dead approach loosely
tied into the show and comics but
directly avoiding the main events
instead we've just got a very pretty
game of Game of Thrones and also that
song at the end really made me cringe is
we first so what you're saying is you
don't like Game of Thrones because it's
too much like Game of Thrones yes but it
has none of the suspense of Game of
Thrones because we already know what's
gonna happen so just feels like filler
anyway I hope I'm wrong and that the
season gets better but episodes 1 & 2
have not filled me with confidence also
now I have semantic satiation for the
phrase Game of Thrones I don't know what
that means
Valar morghulis Valar dohaeris
[Music]
you